I can't anymore it's just a great that
one hey Babu hi I'm JK Aquaman I'm here
playing beer pong I wish you were here
but I'm gonna be reading out some
questions and I hope you guys like it
get us
Oh tell us about your daily we tune Wow
tell us about your daily routine well I
get up I go potty
and yeah just like you same thing damn
damn so much better at this end in high
school mango show us your best dance
move when you were single what was your
best chat up line please please take me
home just to drink that one anymore
thanks lad Babu what's your message
wrong story no
I don't remember Baggett's rebels
describe your relationship it's fish now
that you can talk to them you still eat
them yes I love sushi
I'm pretty good I'm good at this robbed
mango
boat I'm alright is there any other
character you'd like to play from the
comic book world and why yes I'd like to
play Lobo Oh watch this one
the trick with beer pong it's all about
using the force don't aim tamp that was
not a good technique Jon Snow and in
Aries yes or no [ __ ] no I'm Jason
vanilla